hello and welcome to this video playing
save our beer 12 okay let's see Tosh it
has something different here there's
this line that I recently saw a can just
maintain tension and play for an I cube
here it's an interesting way of playing
it and can I still maintain the tension
I think I can
so castles but now I can go five right
that's a fairly good version of a
standard tirage I guess when you have
six now is more difficult to play and
those g5 ideas are completely out of the
window so I think I go here so that I
have night f1 oh that's surprising
and here shuts down the Queen side so
how do I want to play this I think
yeah this is probably good I'm
overthinking probably a little bit here
I have an idea here that had no problem
from a different opening he's playing it
very slowly yeah I'm going for it
you can play g3 first but this is an
interesting Paul sac if he takes it I
get a very quick rookie true okay it
doesn't take it a very quick rookie 3 H
3 so ok I'm taking this and then take
one I add Wow ok doesn't need any
defenders it seems ok let's see how we
do finance here ok a both captures make
sense but I'm sure I think I prefer this
one leads to a bit more fluent peace
play ok on rookie 3 g3 is sir on the
cards I think I'm going for it I mean I
don't care about to be too corny ok I
think he just had just decided to take
everything and and hope that that it's
somehow survives and that he somehow
survives it
kg3
okay so I can t kids I would have to
take it this clear and now Bishop age 6
I don't doesn't really give in
immediately or anything
I can play Queen to e2 attacking this
and threatening Bishop takes h7 you can
take with the pawn of course but then I
take is six releases must be a very
dangerous a check okay this one I have
not really seen that move
hell it's a bit of a shame should be age
six make it really takes you three then
[Music]
it's bad okay
I go to page 693 now we cannot play 93's
so that F Bishop h7 so it's not really
threatening this so let's play it maybe
you can materialize take them okay so
now I have also cool to h5 as a move I
don't know I need to speed up here I'm
threatening whoopsie 7 now winning so he
has to take on g3 ok ok now once in a
while you need to invest a bit of time
black hey guys yeah I don't know I
overlooked an idea for this game and
this is just not playable for black
sorry I mean it is just so this attack
is too strong I would be very surprised
that that would work okay so here Queen
age 5 is plus a million and I came I
mean this also looked dangerous but
probably I should have looked for for
the size of stuff already and there is
the size of stuff we should have 6 is
the threat and he cannot I cannot find
it off yeah that would have been easy
actually
ok here this waiting game is interesting
not playing 5 what black Kevin likes
normal recipe is is to take him and now
play a bishop before 96 something like
that that leads to an IQ p position
obviously something different but he
never did he just played standard moves
and now I mean no I'm into I think a
fairly good version of this opening
where the black has canceled early and
he has for faded options like g5 and
so on and this I don't believe it all
I mean why it has a very standard
checking the setup and this is extremely
slow I mean extremely slow on the
queenside okay the engine is also
suggesting interesting stuff but I like
this idea
the idea is that I want to go very quick
ninety five and deflect a [ __ ] oh I can
play this which is quite dangerous and
that is coming with a tempo Queen comes
out and so on I mean I were taking with
all pieces and I don't see those
defending all that much maybe nine three
seven right it is really dangerous
already played in signals anyway and he
I think it gets very dangerous pawn
takes is also interesting and like try
to to get onto the h-file but that takes
a while and if she moves the rook and
place 9f8 this is to reasonably safe
this is just a bit quicker and also it
can do this kind of thing and the bishop
is just participating in the attack and
here the queen h5 was already killing
what I did is not that good obviously
chair and yeah this is just not working
at you too mighty for didn't see the
move we should see one is good though at
least that's compensation for the pawn
[Music]
but surprise it in that I'm not having
an advantage she okay the center is
crumbling but you check with absolutely
all pieces Yemen - okay then things are
not that clear all of a sudden if the
engine gets a bit of time to calculate
so here here okay Bishop g7 and
the Queen h5 interesting yeah I played
this because um that's my issue
I will you know whatever looked I wanted
to play this and okay you can just play
this move and then I'm out of moves so
that would have won one for him easily
again the test is just checkmate I mean
that's just sick made
yeah sketch again I mean Queen age five
earlier was very strong okay guys thanks
for watching